[Music]
i always wonder when someone like you
comes on the program who has this crazy
unique skill how did you figure out that
you could do this when did you know that
your lips could do this uh well i've
been doing art since i could hold a
crayon and painting sewing metal
smithing
every medium i can get my hands on and
back in 2001 i was getting ready to go
see some band i don't even remember it
was put on my red lipstick blotted it
and saw the lip print and said you know
son of a [ __ ] i can paint with that
like
that's so cool so you're completely
self-taught in this technique uh yeah i
went to school for uh metalsmithing and
ceramics i mean like i said like any
medium i could get my hands on i i used
to actually say when people i wouldn't
even call myself an artist for a long
time
uh people ask me you know what do you do
i make [ __ ] i i just that's what i do
and always looking for new techniques
sure sure any way to express yourself
and then you find this and this has sort
of really taken off for you let's look
at we have some works of art behind the
couch here and we can push in on these
they're absolutely incredible there's
david bowie uh right there and this is
all done with your lips is that correct
yes absolutely fantastic i think below
david bowie is is that hunter s thompson
yes firing a gun right there
absolutely incredible and you don't use
brushes or anything uh i have started
doing more mixed media stuff like
painting on the backgrounds but the
portraits that
you know i don't even sketch with a
pencil it's just my lips right just a
different way of painting okay and this
is audrey hepburn yes behind you and
again
all uh all you using your lips and i'm
just curious
what is the technique is there a special
technique involved do you ever is it
just lips do you ever involve the tongue
when you're making stuff
no you know what i mean come on grow up
that's disgusting these are artistic
questions yeah
yeah
which is something high class yeah
tongue and painting no but i don't know
i i have no idea you can use your teeth
that's what was so fun about it is is
the problem solving and trying to figure
out how i could make different shapes
and you know those those really crappy
websites that are dedicated to making
fun of those the girls on like social
media making the duck faces
right well that's unfortunately that's
it's not a very flattering process when
i paint and i have to make that face
uh and can you make the face for me
right now what's the yo you gotta do
that and you got to kind of distort your
face i did uh i did acting when i was
younger and uh when i was a little kid i
would just make faces in the mirror and
now it's uh that's that's not bad what
i'm doing right now you might have a
future in this you should try it you
know who'd be good at this painting is
donald trump would be good oh yeah yeah
you know
yeah
yeah before you you know and then he
could go paint at home and maybe uh
channel some of that rage
yeah that's
good luck with that um now i want to
mention a lot of the proceeds for this
go to a really good cause i try to do as
much charity stuff as i can i do signed
uh limited edition uh numbered screen
prints of my work and i usually donate
to like the juvenile diabetes research
foundation or the american diabetes
association um i'm on an animus insulin
pump i'm a cyborg
which i enjoy
is the word you use for you have that
pump with you all the time right i um my
pancreas pretty much doesn't produce
enough insulin right so i have to give
it to myself manually so i just i wear a
pump i've been wearing it for 11 years
now wow and then you you raise a lot of
money for this cause that's fantastic
every little bit helps i hope i can help
out so